[Music]
hi everyone thanks for inviting me my
name is CH I'm currently ion post Dr
pharoh H working with f federo and Jacob
Andreas today I will talk about NE
Network models of visual learning and
development
now let me start by telling you
something about DS or puzzles the game
is simple you just try to recover the
picture from its pieces but even simple
games have some general strategies to
play for example um in this video the
person recording it are actually
actively grouping things according to
the visual appearance of the pieces
after the grouping is finished the
person will then match small pieces
corresponding to the image on this
different uh on the on on the original
picture to determine where the position
should ultimately
be so these are the two general
strategies I talked about in solving the
JSO puzzles cly grouping things and fing
matching them to the original
picture both of them are finished by the
visual system and we know that learning
is actually important for the visual
system um we know that from earlier
foundation work by doors hubo and the
WIS and also more recent work where
people have found that seeing faces is
necessary for pH patch formation in
primates the question that I'm going to
talk about in this talk is how to model
this learning and the development
trajectory so what do we know about this
um traj directory we know that children
perceive varying St during development
these are images taken from children um
from their head cameras and the age of
um the recording was labeled on the top
of the images so to represent this I
will use this real world data stream B
with varying color to indicate that it's
changing across the
time so as a results the Dynamics are
very complex and the longitud know
different people may have different
Dynamics and even averaging them um to
get the uh uh to get the Dynamics
average across people there are still
Dynamics happening at the different time
scales in fact the development in the
time scale of years which is what proed
right now should be a result of the
development in the time scale of hours
which I would call the shown as the real
time
Dynamics so how can we model all these
different levels of
Dynamics what I'm going to show you is
that deep networks will have the
potential to model the whole
Dynamics so before doing that let me
first give you a brief introduction to
these
networks um so visual D networks for
example typically receive um inputs in
the very Ro forms meaning images in high
dimensional arrays of
pixels after layers of nonlinear
Transformations early layer of this
network will have lowlevel information
like like Edge and
counters while higher layers will have
more semantically meaningful information
and will typically be lower
dimensional this networks are typically
trained to categorize objects the input
image will have output label um produced
by these networks and these labels will
be compared um to the ground choose
label provided by uh together with image
and the difference between these two
will be used to update the
weights so why am I saying that D
networks is a good candidate for
modeling the Dynamics let me list the
reasons for that um first reason as I
have mentioned in the introduction they
can process data that are similar to
what humans process that makes them
available of capturing intermediate uh
individual level Dynamics when different
people see different things and they can
capture all these
Dynamics second which is a more recent
finding is that after being trained to
categorize these objects um these
networks are similar to the vental
visual passway of adults now what I mean
by this is that the intermediate layers
of this network can accurately predict
neuronal responses in the Venture visual
of stream of parets including area early
area V1 intermediate area V4 and the D
Stream area it similar findings have
also been shown on human brain
responses and the models can also
capture some aspects of human visual
behaviors now it's important to mention
that these models have not captured all
signatures of the Venture visual passway
but they are much better than other
candidates so all these taken together
um deal networks might be similar to the
adult Venture visual passway what might
be some times overlooked is that these
models also have a learning trajectory
that can possibly model the development
trajectory however as was indicated here
these two trajectories are still very
different so in this talk I will talk
about how we can now build ecologically
possible models that can learn um from
the same data stream as children and
adults perceive and then develop just
like
them now the overall takeaway from this
talk is that identified a new family of
unsupervised learning algorithms called
contrastive learning algorithms um yield
um accurate um models of the vual visual
stream um and even when trained on noisy
real world data this algorithm still
work well in model indiv visual
system they also capture some of the
lifelong in the real time learning
Dynamics but not the more recent
algorithms without the contrasting
algorithm
design now before going into the actual
things let me first tell you about why
the current learning of these networks
are wrong um these are nontypical issues
um at the time when I started working on
this and there are really three critical
issues that I'm going to layouts for
you now the first issue is that and also
the biggest issue is that they require
many more labels during training than
humans what I mean by this is that the
models receive actually 1.2 million
labels from the data set that they
trained on which is
imaginet labels are actually critical
for them during rning without labels
they won't be able to update their
weights at
all um meanwhile humans have fewer
labels these are like real world images
taken from the children's perspectives
and the most of them want have the
labels
provided the second issue is that they
are not trained on the correct
data for example image Nets has many
instances of the same category and also
most of the instances will be static
images the infants perceive fewer
instances and they are dynamic in the
temporal
axis the third issue is that they are
trained in offline fashion meaning that
the data will be repeat
presented to the models to train them
I'll talk more about this
later now I have just identified three
critical issues in the learning of these
models next I'm going to talk about
three projects that I and other people
have done each of them um addressing one
of the critical
issues so the first issue is the
requirement of labels now getting rid of
labels is actually not as easy as it SS
it should require a totally new learning
algorithm which figures out what the
output of the network now means and how
the weights should be
updated these algorithms are called
unsupervised learning algorithms but at
the time when I started looking into
this problem these algorithms are
generally not good enough so just to be
specific um these five algorithms are
the algorithms that I have tested all
published in top journals or
conferences let me give you a concrete
example on what the algorithms actually
do for example this is algorithm called
colorization and the way this algorithm
works is that it will um have the GRE
scale image um input on to the network
and the network is trying to predict the
per pixel um current information and
then compare this output to the ground
Choice label and then using this
difference to update the weights so for
people who are interesting understanding
how humans run this aism seems a little
bit weird because we humans don't just
go around and label the color for
things this is indeed one of the reasons
why these earlier algorithms are just
not good
enough they're not good enough
individual tasks which I'm not going
into detail but feel free to check my
publication on
this more importantly they are really
they are really not good enough to model
the visual
system let me show you what this means
so to show this I will first um train
this um uh models um on imag net without
the labels using the corresponding um
loss defined by all these
algorithms after being trained these
networks will then be used to predict
the neuronal responses in the nonhuman
primates um including all the three
areas I mentioned V1 V4 and it in the
visual passway um just to give you more
details about this neuronal response
data set um the input images are 3D
objects um in front of nature
backgrounds that are independent of the
objects um the neuron responses were
taken from primates um watching at the
images in a passive way meaning that
there are no tasks um required for the
primate and the prediction is done by
chaining a linear regr ression um on
some training images and then evaluated
on held out
images so I'll first look at the um
predictivity um on the it area um the
metric that we will look at um is noise
corrected correlation between predicted
and ground choose neuronal responses
higher is B and the highest is
one um here the black bar represents the
superv model and the BR bar represents a
model that totally untrained what we can
see here is that the supervised model
achieves good um good productivity on
predicting it neur responses and is much
better than un Trin
model so how do this um early
unsupervised learning algorithms work in
this
Benchmark what we can see is that
they're really not good enough there is
a very very significant gap between all
these blue bars and the black
bar in the recent years there have been
new um family of unsupervised learning
methods called contrastive learning
algorithms the general idea of these
algorithms is actually very similar to
what we have seen in the jel puzzle
which is that it wants to group um the
input images in their populations but
now the grouping is happening in the
high level representation now what I
mean by this this will give you an
example um for example the image will be
um sampled uh to generate multiple views
of the same image here is one possible
View and these are different
views and the training algorithm will
then U require these different views to
generate similar representations in the
high level meaning that the embedding of
these views should be similar here
embedding is just word word for the low
Dimension representation that's outputed
at the High um layer of the
network but grouping is not just putting
things together because grouping
actually implicitly requires multiple
groups right this is the second
component in this law definition where
it also separates the current embedding
from other
embeddings that a from different
images however after looking at this one
thing that's a little bit weird to us
would be there are actually images in
these other inputs that are similar to
the image um that are the current
inputs why would you separate things um
that are actually very semantically
similar this is exactly the point that
we took um to develop our new algorithm
called the local
aggregation so in this algorithm reason
we aim to semantically aggregate inputs
so how this is
done U we will first look at the
embedding space um this is just scamma
for that including the embeddings of all
possible images um the Red Dot for
example here indicat the embedding for
the current image and what we will do
then is to um group The embeddings into
separate the embeddings into different
groups for example the blue dot here
represents um close Neighbors that are
like very similar to the current input
in this embeding
space and the black dots represents
background neighbors that are similar
but not that
similar while the gray dots uh represent
other
neighbors this algorithm will then um
try to aggregate the representations of
the current inputs and the other views
including the close
neighbors and also separate it from the
background Neighbors while other
neighbors will not be used in doing this
it's forcing the embedding to be
semantically meaningful and also close
to the hard um to the to the
semantically close uh similar embeddings
instead of just being farther away from
all the other
inputs at the time when this algorithm
was published um it achieved the best
results when train on image net and it
was also the first algorithm that surar
is the supervised Alex net which was the
key architecture that triggered the
whole deep learning Revolution so it
really represented uh represents a
milestone um in unsupervised learning
organisms so how do these algorithms
work um in predicting the neural
responses in the vual visual paway here
we will still look at the it
area what we can see is that contrast
algorithm achieve better it productivity
than the earlier algorithm and are now
much comparable to the supervised
model but supervisor model also achieves
good productivity in other areas
including V4 and V1 how do the contast
learning algorithm work
there in fact local aggregation also
achieves High productivity in V1 and
V4 in V4 local agation is actually
better than other contast running
algorism in V1 they are all comparable
to the supervisor
model local aggregation also yields
correct anatomical mapping meaning that
the earlier layer of this model B
predicts V1 area and the intermediate uh
layer of this model B predicts V4 area
and the L later layer of this model
Badger predicts it area so this together
with earlier results really suggest that
this model has the potential to explain
not just the development of the last
layer like it but also the developmental
trajectory of the intermediate layer and
also the earli
layers so what I have just talked about
in this U slide uh in this project is
that the vental visual pathway May learn
and develop like contrastive learning
algorithms in the next project I will
talk about about how the algorithms can
now use data that are less
wrong so what I mean by this is that in
the previous project the models might be
similar to the adult representations but
they are still trained um on a data set
that's very different from what children
actually receive during their
development just to remind you how
different they are models see these band
instances and the static images while
infant they see few instances and the
dynamic so to capture what the children
are actually seeing during their
development we use this um child
Viewpoint data set called cam this data
set is collected by um three children U
by having had cameras on three children
aged from six to 32 months is um and
from the viewpoints of their head
mounted cameras and each child will
roughly receive um a collect two hours
per week and in total there are 600
hours it's still a small collection of
what the children actually see during
development it's a good example of the
actual visual
statistics our next question is then how
to develop a visual a system like
representations from this data
set so intuitively you may think that
now the videos will include the
additional information which is the
temporal information and this should
make it learning easier however it's
actually not easy at all to use this
temperate information
well for example a very popular
hypothesis about leveraging the temporal
information is predictive
coding uh implemented by this pret
algorithm this algorithm will take the
input image um as a previous frame and
then we'll use that image to predict the
next
frame in the video
sequence so how does this algorithm work
in exper nor responses um in V4 and it
um so what we will look at is still this
non-human primate U data but being adult
like in the Venture stream typically
requires also being good on this
Benchmark after evaluating this
algorithm which we find is that there is
significant gap between pret and the
supervised
model so in the previous project I used
this contusive learning algorithms how
about just running them on the steel
frames without using any temporal
information what we can see is that
local agregation actually Brides much of
the Gap although it under uses the
tempor
information so how to further bridge the
gap by leveraging the temple
information to understand how this can
be done let's look at some examples in
the C
videos um for example the children may
look at the similar object from
different View points um in one video
sequence at different video sequences
they may look at different um
objects and different children may look
at different things but the same child
may look at similar things across even
years
lifespan this is this indicates that
learning from loyal kids data is really
harder problem than learning from imet
because there is this long range the
temporal dependency of hours or years um
there are many fewer distinct examp
examples but there will be from a wider
variety of view
points this is exactly the point we took
to develop our new algorithm we leverage
temporal information to decide what to
Aggregate and what to
separate and we will aggregate the view
point of the same object happening in
one video sequence but separate them
from different uh video
sequences we developed this algorithm
called video instance embedding there is
a different um stream of this model that
leverage the temporal information using
temporal convolution which I'm not going
into the details and is also not used in
this
project um but uh at the time of this
algorithm being published it achieved
the best results by very large margins
um in action recognition task and image
categorization
task so VI also
outperforms the previous steel frames
model local aggregation by leveraging
the tempor information in videos as you
you can see there is significant gap
between the green and the um VI
bar however there is still some gap
between training on imag net and the
training on ccam so we still have some
work that we need to
do now this is second project where I
just talked about um how temporal
information can be used and this
indicates that the Venture visual
passway May leverage the temporal
information by aggregating multiple
views of the same
item so in these two projects I talked
about developing better AI algorithms
they also lead to B models for the
Venture stream does this mean that B on
supervisor learning organisms from the
AI Community always more humanlike there
are in fact many new unsupervised
learning organizm I'm just listing some
of them
here however in the next project I will
show you that this is not the
case so in the next project I'll will
talk about how to do human life online
learning now let me first talk about why
offline learning is wrong mentioned that
offline learning represent meaning that
the same data will be repeatedly
presented um to the models it will
generate some trajectory but if we look
at the intermediate point of this
trajectory um they are really not
comparable because for example at this
point children have seen the first 20%
of the data in the Stream but the models
have repeatedly seen all the data 20
times there is just no way that these
two dores can be
comparable in addition to that online
learning is also required for General
model of the development Dynamics in
different time scales this is the
development um scale like in the
lifelong scale in years there is another
time scale which is in the real time
scale in hours so correct model should
also capture the Dynamics in both these
two times scales
so how can we do
that we will first um show the videos
that we uh children received during
their development in the same order to
the models here the appoc number meaning
the presentation order to the
models within one appoc will also show
the frames captured in this video on to
the same order that they are recorded to
the models here the step number meaning
that the represent a pres uh mean a
presentation order to the
models so our aim is then to have the
same algorithm to model learning
Dynamics in both time
scales but only learning from the
current context but um this is actually
not a simple task because if you only
learn from the current context um like
just sample from it and learn from it
you will quickly lose your progress on
earlier
inputs this is why we develop the memory
storage system and we store all the
earlier inputs as memory and we jointly
learn from memory and the current
context now the memory is implemented in
very simple form which is that we store
all the earlier inputs and then we
randomly draw samples from it but we
expect that making it more like human
memory system will also make the
learning better I've just talked about
models need to have a memory module but
only learning from this M will also lead
to failure in adapting to the real time
change so this really indicates a
tradeoff between real time and lifelong
learning on how much memory should be
used in fact how memory is used is also
a critical Dand Point um that vary in
the learning
algorithm I talked about there were many
new unsupervised learning algorithms and
they differ in a critical way in how
memory is used and it's interesting that
they actually differ in a systematic way
that earlier algorithms actively
separate one example from others in the
memory which we call the contrasting
mechanism the recent algorithm no longer
doing that they removed this contrasting
mechanism and just doing embedding
aggregation and as you can imagine this
reason algorithms outperformed earlier
on on typical computer vision benchmarks
like image net but how do these
algorithms model human learning
Dynamics to answer that we will look at
the modeling uh Dynamics in both real
time and lifelong time scales in real
time we will look at the mismatch to
human learning Dynamics measured in
another experiment let me briefly talk
about how this is done in this
experiment human subjects will Ex
relatively go through test and exposure
phases in the exposure phase they will
be asked to just uh click the dot when
it appears
um
um and then in this condition for
example when two faces are used there
will be different faces um hopefully you
can see them um and in another condition
there will be the same
faces so when they look at the different
faces they will be further ask to which
was in the test phase and uh as you can
imagine um the differ phes were to
decreasing accuracy Sy phis will lead to
increasing accuracy which is captured in
this
figure and uh um so again we are trying
to model this learning Dynamics and what
we're going to look at is a mismatch
score where lower is better and the
lowest is
1.0 so the algorithms that are not doing
memory contrasting actually um do not so
well on this Benchmark they are
significantly higher than the lowest
amount
and if we look at the actual uh actual
learning Dynamics for example this
algorithm barely captures the learning
Dynamics while this algorithm captures
some but not too
much so the algorithm however the
algorithms doing memory contesting
actually do much better they
consistently outperform algorithm
without contrasting this Benchmark and
if you look at one of them they captured
most of the dynamic though not all of
them this is only on one um time scale
of the learning Dynamics how about the
lifelong time
scale now remember that um in this uh
evaluation the models will be trained on
the videos that children perceive during
the developments and what we will look
at is then the um categorization
accuracy um averaged across the learning
trajectories and here higher is better
and we use this as a proxy for human
likeness um what we're going uh what we
can see is that when evaluated on this
um algorithms without memory contesting
uh really mostly failed on this time
scale although there is one algorithm
that does not so bad this algorithm
totally failed in the realtime Benchmark
this is the ma algorithm that's actually
the most popular unsupervised learning
algorithm uh right now but algorithm
with contrasting
consistently outperformed algorithms
without
contrasting if we put them together this
really indicates that we cannot simply
wait for AI advances the recent AI
algorithm really diverge from being
humanlike because the recent algorithms
have already removed this memory
contrasting
mechanism Rec earlier I mentioned that
there is a trade off between these two
time scales um what I'm going to show is
that that with the same model um if you
use less memory the real-time learning
uh Dynamics will be uh uh worse but if
you use more memory the real time sorry
the lifelong learning Dynamics will be
worse but if you use more memory the
real-time learning Dynamics is worse so
this is captured in this
figure okay so what I have just drawn in
this project is that the Venture visual
passway May leverage memory for Learning
and the developing in both year long and
hour long time scale
um however you should not just use the
recent AI
algorithms so in this talk we started
from having this three critical issues
in the learning of visal dipl networks
re of labels not train on correct data
and training in this offline fashion um
through my works on building stronger
learning algorithms and also linking
them to the Venture visual pathway and
also building the realtime learning and
lifelong learning um Dynamics um we are
not much closer to using these models to
model the whole development
trajectory of course this is still not
the end for example humans develop
multiple modalities uh simultaneously so
we want to in the future we want to
integrate the development of other
modalities like language and addition um
at the same time these models should
also be better models of neuron
responses from developing visual systems
like infant visual cortex
responses finally we also want to build
the models with more inductive bias like
we know that humans represent objects in
special way so want to integrate that in
the models and the check how they will
improve um the modeling of the Dynamics
in the
trajectories at last um I want to thank
the people who I have worked with on
this project without their help um this
project will really not be
available and thank you all for your
attention feel free to check the
Publications and also contact me if you
have
questions